with the ease of international travel
and the pace of modern life at greater
potential for viruses to spread further
and faster and as the government
declares coronavirus a serious and
imminent threat just how concerned
should we be here in Brighton with
coronavirus on the doorstep it's a
reality people are having to face it's
one thing seeing it on the news and then
it's one thing to actually seeing it
around the corner poking through the
window seeing the people in the hazmat
suits it was bad enough to you it was
from Brighton but I wasn't expecting
from my neighborhood that's very
worrying I think we're getting a bit
sort of over the top about it really
tens of thousands of people have
contracted this latest strain of
coronavirus so far the death rate is
estimated just over two percent compared
that with SARS which killed 10 percent
of people and MERS which killed a third
while flu has less than a 1% mortality
rate but there is an important
difference between that and this
coronavirus people built a community to
the flu so there over time they're
exposed so that the flu tends to be
really mostly a problem for those who
are elderly or have some other
underlying conditions the other I think
critical difference is that for the
annual influenza we have a vaccine and a
fairly effective vaccine and that of
course reduces the morbidity mortality
the race is on to develop such a vaccine
for this coronavirus but it's unlikely
to be noose much before the end of the
year as new cases continue to rise some
people aren't taking any chances with a
big increase in demand for face masks
I've managed to get hold of this
specialist one which has a filter and a
valve but most people are going out and
buying surgical masks so how much
protection do they offer they're not
able to really filter out finer
particles such as viruses any mask
really is only as good as the person
wearing it as well because if you were
to wear a mask and then take it off and
not wash your hands and then touch your
eyes or eat some food you've just risked
contaminating yourself as well so the
message is now is not the time to panic
washing your hands is still the best
form of prevent
chin burst it's early days with this
form of coronavirus and no one really
knows how it will develop Charlotte
Lomas Sky News